I know as you know you certainly get to
the moment to another so you know all
that best time that hugs go to hear any
other apologies that I think are already
on their return though non members
attending minutes of the meeting held on
32 jewel Isaac or wish I started as a
true record very very encouraging any
declarations of interest please any
arise during the meeting please declare
room at that time and we'll make sure
they recorded if you were to mind so
going straight to item sit or sorry
there are no items referred on so go
straight to item 6 find it give you up
which is progress on decisions so can I
throw it open to members for raising
points on there on that particular
budget of that particular agenda looking
for up longer set up perhaps i'll just
go through the pages if i may so 6.10
down the 6.2 please come back if you
want to go back again 6.3 6.4 i think
cheering for my at least we need to
progress and make some comment as to
where we feel you should have wish your
progress on this one it keeps being
raised some of the some of the findings
are disappointing we should be safe from
what says the exit survey do you want us
as a environment a portfolio to start
looking at various options that may be
worthwhile bringing false and i know
there are some frozen coming forward all
regular it's essential that we look at
those options coming forward and trying
i think we need to really sort of if you
like put a
a real sort of marker on this so that we
know exactly where we're going for next
year I pressure home and take it forward
yes there are options I mean some of the
options are quite palatable some of them
all yeah and clearly we got to give
regard to bigger areas of shopping etc
as to how that goes forward public
demand whether there's other
availability whether it's just holiday
availability you know that sort of thing
but I'm sure that we can get to the
bottom of this and it may require some
investment as well I further it's about
investing in the long term to save money
working on so perhaps with a town or
parish council partner and maybe even
working with businesses who knows okay
and take things forward okay yep I girly
also that about 6.5 yes please Thank You
chairman can we ascertain where we are
with the highway Rangers and their
functions on your marriages every time
it comes up on the agenda every time you
ask them to do something that's a reason
why they can't do it you can't do it 30
mile limit Rose I can't release the car
to that you know where are we with this
place um I can make something do it
tremendously warns about latest works
that the Rangers have been doing didn't
provide me with some information a
little while ago but on it only to check
on that I didn't think this that they
are out there they are doing works but
but if you leave it with me I'll get an
update on the latest work programme
circulate night I think there was
something that went through LHP possible
that some of you were making the has
been yes yes it has been yet yeah so it
might be useful to have a look at that
do we get a list of where that guy
should be working so members took to all
members of the things that need to be
done but we're not aware how be really
helpful I'll be very helpful I can ask a
question
go forward so we go where the going to
be in the last time we sensible one
excellent so however recently something
I probably should have noticed long time
ago on the pilot amenity scheme they
said notice it this statement there is
the county council asked if that we
could extend from nine to one rather
than nine till known what was behind
that but they paying for of the extra
hour i think is extra half an hour isn't
there so I think it's classic now ago
well I know that they're supposed to
start a hot last night you know most
other areas they do but i think there's
extra monies paid to start at nine just
a strange one that you know that's only
different though I oh nothing else asked
us to do an extra hour I we're talking
about 6.5 my week yeah yeah yeah it's
got it my gosh I thought or anywhere a
bike so I think I think that was a
request from the residence as much as
anything until it was personal reasons
just slowly there'll be a cost to that
but yeah not that 40 what 20 houses on
twenty five percent more time it's just
a small metal thing I probably should do
notice it a long time ago but nothing I
think it was very much as has been
suggested that it was fun related to who
wanted a little bit way Lex ability in
terms of the time ESO st. Anne's County
Council be asked yeah well I just don't
know nose but one of them I mean are
they coming at us today no no no it's
just an imagined legwork I bring the
book then it's actually 33 Pacific you
think about it because three hours
x-trail would be there 33 disappear now
I think carefully aren't County covering
some of it I've been lucky no no one
time they do but I don't know any way
that we just have a trying to get
feedback on that one if you please even
though it's actually yeah it's just so I
don't think there was a third extra cost
for third our field no you probably be
little just
perfectly honest I'm trapper edge of
town unnoticed there and if you've got
one person driving there's a sonic
trouble over overseeing it's one
person's best for an x-ray oh yeah which
wouldn't be not an addition for a lot of
them I don't know it might well have a
look at that it is very popular but
moving on 6.6 6.76 18.9 16 11 12 close
it up up here oh yes I think we've now
sort of that our play spaces refurbish
from the half of my soul and that's gone
through so let's work very well sir 13
14 15 16 and that's it what let's accept
the report no report thank you I'll take
it as a yes just go back to 612 oh well
oh no tourists to comment on the report
being able to measure taken to new
committee last night but it's going to
go back with the draft action plan
unfold okay I mean is there much that we
can do other than monitor no but we're
sure may be able to help me on this one
we are counting consultants to verify
the data refer be taught and all the
draft action plan and that is in
painted the environment my office so
that will be ready in time to go back to
review see through you another one to
scrutinize that I seem to remember
reading your report that Parliament or
actually looking at air quality
management of the moment some areas and
they're going to take some ministation
forward so we need to keep a weather eye
on that as well at the moment as an
authority feel like we have no teeth
there's nothing we can actually do to
folks that me there are certain things
that we could do in other areas where we
had pollution from industrial sites and
that sort of thing and we've done that
but in this particular case there's not
actually can do as far as that's
concerned and it might be you know the
only case i can put forward is to count
it as things like traffic flow of that
sort of thing to my mind with the
rayleigh it's always a case of coming
through Rowley it's when you've got a
mixture of people and cars that's what
holds the traffic out there and the
seemly when I came back here it wasn't
too bad at all because a lot of the
people finish their shopping and it's
just the traffic coming through so you
know it's how you get over that if you
like I mean interview if you recall well
here maybe other have a bit more than we
had this presentation probably over a
year ago now hmm where county were going
to go away and come back they had the
animation of traffic flow they would
come back without a plane where you know
you control pelican crossings of rather
than just ordinary zipper across in a
bit traffic flow could be controlled it
sent under the day I think they bully
yeah yeah and that I think they like
both one presentation baggage and I
think many of us ever saw I know why
we've never heard from again working
it only went to the nhp reviewing and
then 10 if I ok if you come up with the
last LHP meeting because there was a
couple of other suggestions after we see
Meg and they were going to go back and
come back to us again with modeling
around those other suggestions which
they hadn't done so please not be lost
those it should come back I'm not sure
when the next eligible meeting is it's
we've got a pre-meeting on the
thirteenth and the meeting of these two
2050 skits crazy there's not a theater
hot job that is my German we we had an
initial input into this particular
modeling but since then we've had no
subsequent impulse and that is
appointing you know in as much as that
we hire RT certain things but they
seemingly didn't realize were apparent
and we felt that there was a we've been
missing from the puzzle but we've never
got any further back on that is it was
those things that they hadn't gone back
and done which I've asked them at the
last LHP to go back and do it but so
they though it's yeah ladies any large
ocular thank you just to clarify the
pre-meeting philosophies and thirteenth
and then the hall meetings on the
twenty-second and you right so moving
forward then the finance portfolio
quarter financial management report
you've got the report there I don't know
if you want to say a genetic please
should an assignment and matt'll take
any detailed questions however if I
could take you to 7.3 where this the
overall forecasts particularly the
bottom right figure there
on budget some information has very
recently come to light that expend that
figure could be you want the 7.3 it
could be 200,000 pounds adrift so
forecast is more like a hundred thousand
3.5 gig the second paragraph obviously
gives a slightly misleading information
the other item in 3.5 is treasured
treasury management with the increased
caution that review committee requested
and with the lack of investment return
following the the brexit vote the the
targets that were worse at are clearly
not going to be met so there's a drop
there in what was proposed as income but
and it over to Matt to take any other
detailed questions or any other
information you hot rod they will train
so it's got to be a good report baby
raise it as I say it's a slightly open
by Vince and that's why these things
sometimes but you know that's the way
the business that were in unfortunately
I you know obviously with the the
homeless they that the figure was for
homeless is short term beyond our
control it was it was going to be what
it was going to be just the indicators
perhaps need to be looked at okay well
that 200,000 is a worse position it may
even possibly be better than that like
at the implication clearly we have to
look at the worst pacifica and so the
right thing that we should do what I
would add to that gem is a quarter tues
report will become
to exec in October and that will give a
thorough detail position where we're at
with homeless and the plans and apache
answer to mitigate overspends thank you
right so if there's no other questions
recommendations no course 1 and capital
position contained in paragraphs 34 and
show me an appendix 1 and 2 to know the
Greek author 1 16 17 capital monitoring
report in appendix 2 and so the current
financial performance with obviously
modifications or key revenue financial
educators as shown indices three and
four members agreed very very right I
think we're now going into private
confidential so why are take the
exclusion resolution is being read yes
yes thank you very much indeed right